design is supposed to resolve usability
problems yeah why then are our apps and
devices creating more anxiety within
each use because they're designed for
the for the outcomes that the companies
want and designs not just about
usability it's about your designing for
particular life experiences and outcomes
and designers have to are not
necessarily like we were just talking
about the user experience you know
designers are not inherently there to
serve their users or their customers
designers are there to enact a
particular sort of mission that is
articulated to them right so the the
design in that sense is an ability to to
fuse between the engineering world and
the experiential world and I have a PhD
in design studies so like for me design
is all about the process of opening up
or opening off different pathways of
living and experience yeah so that's
what I think of design as you know sort
of a ways to to rule to relate people to
experiences to technologies to
narratives yeah well I mean they're
their job is to aggregate eyeballs and
it makes me think of the coronavirus if
if the media can make you paranoid and
scared about the coronavirus well then
what are you gonna do you're gonna keep
checking for watching yeah you're gonna
keep watching because they were to tell
you the opposite hey it's fine you're
not gonna come back right exactly
so the yeah and it's unfortunately that
like we we are when we are emotional
that is when we react and that's when
we're you know looking for things we run
away from pain we run towards pleasure
and it's unfortunate that the the media
in general I'm not saying every single
media outlet Josh and are having this
conversation earlier I said the media's
like what do you mean by the media I'm
just talking about by and large you know
a large percentage of the media they use
fear they don't use happiness they don't
use good feelings they use bad feelings
because we are more apt to look out for
that a that anxious feeling because
guess what if we can go to a news outlet
and oh you know this is where I know the
coronaviruses and these are the places I
need to avoid and this is what I need to
do to avoid the coronavirus it's going
to subside that anxiety
little bit but there's still enough
there to keep us going back am impulsive
and compulsive behavior yeah right yeah
compulsive compulsive behavior it is
pretty easy to control and route you
know and stimulate what's the echo
Ryan's point we do have to start to call
out some of the individuals as well I
heard what was his name scott g on sam
Harris's podcast recently he was talking
about how he thinks mark zuckerberg is
the most dangerous man in the world I
gotta get on that podcast and kind of
push push that a little further I mean I
look I think I think I mean I I think
there's a lot of different ways we could
dissect that right so like of course
Mark Zuckerberg in many ways is more
powerful than a head of state
I remember when during the Obama
administration when the Prime Minister
of India came to the u.s. for like a
state meeting with Obama before Narendra
Modi who I is awful in my opinion and is
inciting through the use of social media
lots of anti-muslim violence as we speak
in India but before he came to meet
Obama he came to Silicon Valley to meet
Mark Zuckerberg yes I mean I think I
think Mark Zuckerberg is it is is it
like a lot of engineers a lot of execs
who are not really exposed to or maybe
able to really engage with these kind of
systemic humanizing kinds of issues
human centric issues is detached is is
is is disconnected many of the
connectors are disconnected I met Mark
Zuckerberg 10 years ago I was in grad
school at Harvard when he was an
undergraduate
along with Pete Buddha judge actually
and and you know I when I met him ten
years ago I just saw this sort of you
know he also first he offered me
intimate Facebook data ten years ago I
decided not to go there because I was
more interested in working with
indigenous communities and power to the
people kind of stuff like my books about
but then I noticed a sort of a sort of
detached agnosticism you know and that's
very common in our engineering fields we
don't really infuse humanistic thinking
emote emotive thinking
at thick's oriented thinking political
thinking in our engineering schools and
this is one of the things I'm really
trying to push at UCLA where I teach
like we got a we're trying to build data
and society programs but we got to have
them be about society too not just data
well you know there's got to be some
like cognitive dissonance when you're
someone like Mark Zuckerberg yeah I mean
he is he obviously puts money first and
if you're if you're going at it that way
like you you have to ignore some of the
systemic problems that you're creating
and couple other elements to that the
Facebook has a hidden system which is
that some some reporters have exposed
called the dual class share system which
means that if all the investors in
Facebook chose to kick out mark they
wouldn't be able to because his class of
shares is in a different category this
is something this is like the hidden
political economy that one has to look
at and second is it's pretty notable to
look at how a lot of the tech bazillion
airs you know like Bezos included who
didn't pay taxes like their companies
don't pay much of any taxes even though
they profit from all our socialized
costs right like roads and etc and the
internet itself how they are investing
so much in post-apocalyptic bunkers kind
of dr. Strangelove style and space oh
well it's kind of like you know Tribe
Called Quest has this line in their last
record we're like you know it's called
the space program this like awesome song
that they put out being like we're stuck
here and the rest of them are out of
here